we begin this morning with the aftermath
of a terrifying shooting spree in
washington that left four people injured
including a child the gunman opened fire
friday in a busy neighborhood just as
students at a nearby private school were
being dismissed the suspect later took
his own life as law enforcement closed
in police have not determined a motive
for the attacks christina raffini is at
the scene of the shooting about three
miles northwest of the white house
christina good morning
good morning michelle well there's a
welcome calm in this neighborhood this
morning but that wasn't the case
yesterday where it was wall-to-wall
first responders along this major road
in washington where police were
searching in some places door-to-door
looking for that shooter the suspect
that we believe is responsible for this
is now deceased
multiple guns and ammunition were found
in a fifth floor apartment along with
the suspected gunman who police say took
his own life as they broke down the door
this was very much a sniper type set up
his intent was to kill and hurt members
of our community
law enforcement descended on this
neighborhood in northwest d.c shortly
after 3 30 p.m on friday the advice i'm
on the scene of an active shooter person
shot in the alleyway when witnesses say
multiple volleys of semi-automatic
gunfire rang out just minutes before
kids were about to be released for the
day from this private school i heard
several shots ring out and then what
seemed to be either continuing or
returning fire
[Music]
four people were shot one of them a
child
police team searched the area including
this apartment building but did not find
the shooter they then named 23 year old
raymond spencer a person of interest
saying they'd identified him through
social media posts
a video of what appears to be a
first-person shooter view of the attack
surfaced online shortly after the
incident
it looks to me like i said like he's in
our building that looks like the alley
is walking towards first
and this is the alley that you said the
pickup and drop-off is for the kids yeah
the end of that alley mason kalphus
lives in the building used by the gunman
and his 14 year old son attends the
school what's the first thing you're
going to do when you see him
i don't know hug him and
just you know we'll go to dinner and
have him have a great night
mason and his son were later reunited
now police will not name the man they
say they found dead in that apartment
but they also said they are no longer
looking for that person of interest jeff
christina thank you